Tom Hanks's movie, "Cast Away", is a great tale, entertaining, and has a good message.
Only one problem, the beach in the movie was clean.
In four years, only one piece of junk drifted ashore.
Now there's a real fairy tale!
In real life, a castaway would have more than a volleyball for company.
He would have the entire Wilson clan, an extended Spalding family,...
...and a set of off-brand cousins.
He would also have a whole pile of slippers and sneakers to go with them.
Is size a problem? Just wait a few days.
Catching rainwater in coconut shells? Please.
In four years, Hanks would have enough bottles and containers to stock a bar.
Why waste energy trying to spear fish with a stick?
It's far easier to net them with the discarded fishing nets that would...
...almost certainly be on that beach.
The fire - starting scene was funny, but in reality...
...there are lighters washed onto beaches around the world and some still contain butane.
Plastic fishing floats litters virtually every tropical beach in the world.
Coming in various shapes and sizes,...
...and lashed together with the thousands of feet of rope that would also have washed ashore,...
...Hanks could have made an unsinkable boat.
With the stuff lying on beaches today, you could build a whole house,...
...complete with furniture, and as the movie showed, a real outhouse.